hey guys good to see you
so did the johns break out the 20-sided
diet to actually direct the film was
like rolling the diamond and saying okay
this is how you're going to do this now
i'm just having to do that now based on
the role
not with me but with hugh a lot just to
kind of activate them and and get the
performance they wanted which is hard to
get me interested yeah so yeah they were
talking about this dnd game that they
had you guys sit down and play to get
the feel of it what was that like to do
together
miserable when he was playing but
otherwise really quite fun uh hugh
yeah well i enjoyed it
i we
we played an interesting uh naked
version of the game
which
wait who doesn't play the indie naked oh
i didn't know that
i thought it was special to us well
anyway
it was it was terrific wasn't it just a
tuesday night yeah yeah too many bottles
of wine yeah so this crowd must have
been the perfect one to debut this
footage with did you actually sit down
with them to watch the trailer that's
what i had heard that you had gone to
sit with it i'd seen a roughed out
version of the trailer when we're
sitting it's just too hard to
watch the clips and stuff so i've done
it before you know when i was here with
wonder woman or whatever you just sit
down and get a front row seat yeah um
everybody knows well d d fans know about
the different roles that different
characters play
i saw a photo that said that you're the
bard is there a lot of singing for you
you've got a loot in the trailer you
have a loot there may be some singing uh
there's definitely a lack of uh
practical skill
a
heavy on on
on charm and slow wit but uh that's a
bard would you agree with that
assessment of his singing skill
i enjoyed your singing very much he's
doing himself down and he's good on that
loot uh very good very good and uh
what can i tell you and also a brilliant
performance i'm the first to hate my
co-stars
but i don't know
he's
the royal bollocks
american
well
good good
yeah we'll take that thanks guys